lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
usar la calculadora gráfica para
responder preguntas relacionadas con la
distribución binomial lo cual es útil
porque si van a realizar el examen ap de
estadística por ejemplo les van a
permitir usar una calculadora gráfica
así que esto puede ahorrarles mucho
tiempo a la hora de resolver exámenes la
probabilidad de encestar un tiro libre
es de 0.35 cuál es la probabilidad de
encestar 4 de 7 tiros libres esta es una
pregunta clásica de variables aleatorias
binomial es definimos la variable
aleatoria binomial x como el número de
tiros libres encestados en siete
ejecuciones con una probabilidad de
éxito igual a 0.35 por lo que la
pregunta es cuál es la probabilidad de
que la variable aleatoria binomial x sea
igual a 4
ahora vamos a usar una función de
nuestra calculadora gráfica de 84 que se
llama vino pdf que significa función de
distribución de probabilidad binomial
esta función tiene tres argumentos
es el número de ejecuciones en este caso
es 7 y si están resolviendo esto en la
sección de respuestas abiertas del
examen de estadística se debe indicar
que esto es nuestra n quienes califican
el examen estarán buscando estas
indicaciones para asegurarse de que no
están adivinando cómo poner las cosas el
segundo argumento es la probabilidad de
éxito que es 0.35 y si están resolviendo
esto en un examen también tienen que
indicar que esto es la probabilidad p
finalmente tenemos que indicar la
probabilidad de que nuestra variable
binomial al realizar siete ejecuciones
con una probabilidad de éxito de 0.35
tenga exactamente cuatro éxitos saquemos
nuestra calculadora hay dos formas de
hacer esto una es escribir todo esto
directamente aunque puede llevar algo de
tiempo a hacerlo
la otra es oprimir botón segundo luego
oprimir el botón de distribución en
color azul y para llegar a la función
nos movemos hacia abajo o hacia arriba
para llegar al final de la vista aquí
está la función que nos interesa y nos
pide
podemos usar la combinación alfa para
llegar aquí rápidamente o podemos
movernos aquí con las flechas y damos
enter ahora escribimos el número de
ejecuciones que queremos en este caso
son siete ejecuciones la probabilidad de
éxito para cada ejecución es de 0.35
finalmente el valor de x que es la
probabilidad de que la variable
aleatoria binomial sea igual a 4 o que
el número de éxitos sea igual a 4 ahora
vamos a pegar 6 y con esto ya tenemos la
función con los argumentos que nos
interesan exactamente como los
escribimos aquí 7 ejecuciones una
probabilidad de éxito de 0.35 y queremos
la probabilidad de tener exactamente
cuatro éxitos damos enter y el resultado
es 0.14 lo escribimos esto es
aproximadamente igual a 0.14 con base en
la misma variable aleatoria binomial
ahora nos preguntan la probabilidad de
ese estar menos de cinco tiros libres
esta es la probabilidad de que nuestra
variable x sea menor que 5
la probabilidad de que x sea menor o
igual a 4 la razón por la que escribí
esto de esta manera fue para poder usar
la función de distribución acumulada
binomial en nuestra calculadora
escribimos vino cdf que es la función de
distribución acumulada binomial los
argumentos de esta función son las siete
ejecuciones la probabilidad de éxito de
0.35 y ahora el 4 que escribimos aquí no
significa que tenga una x igual a 4 o
que tenga cuatro éxitos exactamente
ahora significa la probabilidad de
lograr cero uno dos tres o cuatro éxitos
de las siete ejecuciones todos los
posibles resultados para mi variable
aleatoria hasta cuatro éxitos incluyendo
el cuatro sacamos la calculadora y de
nuevo oprimimos segundo distribución nos
movemos hacia arriba para llegar al
final de la lista y aquí tenemos la
función de distribución acumulada
binomial la seleccionamos damos enter y
escribimos siete ejecuciones la
probabilidad es 0.35
x es 4 pero no se refiere a que mi
variable aleatoria de binomial sea igual
a 4 sino a la probabilidad de tener
cualquier cantidad de éxitos hasta 4
incluyendo lo el resultado debe ser
mayor que el resultado anterior damos
enter y tenemos que es aproximadamente
igual a 0.94 lo escribimos espero que
encuentren útil esto pues las
calculadoras nos pueden ayudar mucho
especialmente en los exámenes de
estadística nos vemos en otro vídeo